ich grüße sie herr zidane
das ist heute unser thema dieses land
zwischen dem kaspischen meer und dem
persischen golf flankiert unter anderem
von afghanistan und pakistan von saudi
arabien dem irak und der türkei
was genau passiert dort im iran und wie
ist es dazu gekommen
wir diskutieren und wir zeigen ihnen
heute ausnahmsweise um halb elf schon an
im kinofilm der sie iran ein stück weit
besser verstehen hilft
wie funktioniert der iranische
gottesstaat
wieso kämpfen präsident ahmadinedschad
und der oberste religiöse führer ali
khamenei um die macht ein gespräch
bereits um halb elf der preisgekrönte
zeichentrickfilms persepolis ein
poetisch berührung der einblick in 20
jahre islamische republik mit den augen
von marjane satrapi
der iran hat viele gesichter im westen
kennen wir vor allem die bilder
machtvoller mullahs doch die persische
kultur gehört zu den ältesten der mensch
hat ein gespräch
seit der islamischen revolution von 1979
sind im iran die islamisten an der macht
und seitdem dominieren bärtige mullahs
und verschleierte frauen das bild dieses
landes schließlich vor drei jahren
plötzlich bewegung im verkrusteten
gottesstaat ein heftig aufflammender
bürgerprotest
doch vergeblich jetzt toben die
machtkämpfe einmal zwischen religiösen
hardlinern und reformen und gleichzeitig
zwischen präsident mahmud ahmadinedschad
und ayatollah khamenei dem obersten
religiösen führer was ist der
hintergrund dieser rivalitäten um was
bedeuten sie für die menschen im jahr
rita becker hat zur klärung den iranisch
deutschen journalisten und
politikwissenschaftler kamera farian
eingeladen
nach jahren der arabische frühling hatte
eigentlich im iran begonnen
wir wurden 2009 zeugen eines riesigen
bürgerprotest warum hat das da nicht
funktioniert wie beispielsweise in
ägypten oder tunesien wo die regimes
gestürzt wurden das ist eine der
grössten tragödien der neueren
iranischen geschichte der islamischen
republik sozusagen das dort wo
eigentlich 2009
der arabische frühling wobei wir kein
arabisches land sind überhaupt dieser
aufstand unter den menschen begonnen hat
ist nicht zum erfolg geführt hat bis zum
heutigen tage leider das hat einen ganz
plausiblen einfachen aber auch
hässlichen grund nämlich die
sicherheitskräfte revolutionsführer
khomeini hat es nach der revolution 179
sehr gut verstanden weil er damals
gesehen hat was eine parallele zu den
arabischen revolutionen ist dass die
armee sich als neutral erklärt hat und
zu den menschen übergelaufen ist seine
eigene garde seine eigene lag gerade die
pasdaran die revolutionswächter ins
leben zu rufen die diesen diese
revolution 2009 brutal niedergeschlagen
haben und die menschen bis heute folter
in den gefängnissen den kerkern der
islamischen republik und das ist der
einfache grund weswegen es leider im
iran bis heute nicht zu einer revolution
gekommen ist sie selbst in 1969 in
teheran geboren sie sind sohn eines
persischen vaters und einer deutschen
mutter
sie sind im iran aufgewachsen ihre
familie ist dann im zuge der revolution
19 79 nach deutschland ausgewandert wie
gut können sie sich an diese
revolutionszeit erinnern sehr gut es war
ein sehr prägendes erlebnis für mich als
jugendlicher ich war zehn elf jahre alt
was ich mich besonders erinnern kann ist
dass es plötzlich in den schulen wir
saßen in der schule in der klasse ist
hieß die schule wird überfallen die
kinder wird mitgenommen die front wenn
sie sich erinnern 1980 im august
begannen der hässliche krieg gegen den
irak der fast acht jahre gedauert hatten
über eine millionen opfer forderte ich
habe auf den straßen natürlich die
schießereien mit bekommen wenn sie
nachts auf die bücher gegangen haben
allahu akbar gott ist groß gerufen das
war eine volksrevolution die alle
gesellschaftlichen schichten quasi an
sich gebunden hat wenn man war den schal
leid der eine eine turbo verwestlichung
dieses landes voran gebracht hat ich bin
im iran aufgewachsen mit walt disney mit
coca cola coca cola statt koran
die iraner sind doch in ihrer großen
zahl auch gläubige menschen haben
religion ist identitätsstiftend und der
schah das leider nicht verstanden diese
balance herzustellen sich eine turbo
verwestlichung und eben trotzdem die
identität der menschen zu bewahren die
menschen hatten sich entfremdet von
ihrer eigenen identität und hatten so
eine back to the roots wollten wieder
zurück zu ihren wurzeln
der star wurde als marionette der usa
richtig richtig also wurde als
marionette gesehen sie haben es ja
gesagt
253 gab es einen verheerenden putsch
gegen den damaligen einzige wählt
ministerpräsidenten des iran mohammed
mossadegh ein traum dass wir bis heute
quasi erleben und vieles sollte
natürlich auch aus der abhängigkeit
gegenüber den amerikanern es waren über
300.000 militärberater im land entweder
hatten das gefühl der iran wurde einem
westen verkauft und dementsprechend bei
der hass
auf den star der natürlich sich als
sonnenkönig auch dargestellt hat und
auch als diktator herrscht es gab nur
eine partei ist kaum gewerkschaften
es gab keine meinungsfreiheit es gab
diesen berüchtigten geheimdienst awag
und dagegen haben sich natürlich die
menschen auf gehen das haben wir als
bürger natürlich hautnah miterlebt die
menschen haben ja die revolution richtig
dabei gesehen also komani ist aus dem
französischen exil zurückgekehrten würde
jubel empfang also da man damals hat man
sich ja nicht vorstellen können wohin
der rumäne wurde als heilsbringer
gefeiert die ganze intellektuellen irans
die auch im ausland waren unter den star
andersdenkende oppositionelle sind zu
ihm gepilgert novelle chateau in einem
vorort bei paris aber auch die menschen
im iran mein eigener vater hat sich an
einem generalstreik beteiligt und wenn
ich ihnen heute frage wieso hast du das
damals gemacht bewusst wusstest du nicht
was auf uns zukommt sagte er nein wir
wussten dass nicht wir dachten es gibt
eine öffnung es gibt eine demokratie was
aber dann passierte als sich die
geistlichen eben an die spitze der
oppositionsbewegung gesetzt haben die
eigentliche aus kommunisten aus den
sogenannten federn mudschaheddin also
marxistischen gruppen aber auch der
nationalen front zusammengesetzt hat als
die sich zerstritten hatten hat sich
dann die geistlichkeit eine spitze der
bewegung gesetzt und hat quasi dann eine
islamisierung eine religiöse diktatur
etabliert die bis heute andauert was
haben sie heute für ein verhältnis zum
iran
naja mit einem lachen einem weinenden
auge wenn ich zurück in den iran gehe
ich bin nach 20 jahren damals zum ersten
mal zurück gegangen und ich habe
wirklich geheult als ich die straßen und
die verzweifelten menschen diese
stimmung da erlebt habe die ich
natürlich aus meiner kindheit ganz
anders kannte
es war ein fröhliches land das waren
nette menschen das sind sie eigentlich
auch geblieben aber es ist eine absolute
wie schon sagte islamisierung der
lebensbereiche eine absolute kontrolle
es herrscht keine meinungsfreiheit und
die menschen sind völlig verzweifelt
haben sich quasi in ihr privatleben
zurückgezogen in der öffentlichkeit
sehen sie nur verschleierte menschen
frauen vor allem natürlich und man kann
sie aber auch als man da nicht frei
bewegen konnte zum beispiel wenn ich
einen mann
reichen reisen in iran dann einfach
joggen wollte oder einfach sport treiben
wollte war das schlecht schwer möglich
auch ich musste lange klamotten anziehen
insofern war das ein richtiger schock
für mich als ich nach jahren wieder in
den iran zurück kehrte und dieses land
einfach nicht wiedererkannt
im westen wird der iran ja sehr
einseitig negativ wahrgenommen
holocaust-leugnung atombombe steinigung
das sind bilder die einem in den sinn
kommt frustriert sie das nicht total
zumal ich ja selbst bei den medien auch
arbeite aber ich muss sagen der iran ist
ein sehr facettenreiches aber auch
paradoxes land das heißt man kann den
iran nicht so oder so beschreiben
natürlich wird im westen dazu tragen wir
als medien leider auch öfter mal bei als
atombomben staat und als ein land voller
bärtiger mullahs und wo frauen
gesteinigt werden dargestellt aber wenn
sie in den iran fahren viele kollegen
sind ein guter kollege ist gerade im
iran gewesen sagte das ist ein ganz
wunderbares und auch vielschichtiges
land die menschen sind trotzdem
natürlich offen
sie sehen auf den straßen viele zwar
verschleierte frauen aber es ist wieder
immer wieder ein kampf auch gegen diese
sittenpolizei der schleier rutscht ein
bisschen nach hinten
die frauen die menschen lassen sich ihre
freiheit nicht nehmen es ist also ein
sehr facettenreiches land und wie ich
auch immer wieder versuche in meinen
berichten zu erwähnen es gibt auch diese
privatsphäre das heißt viele menschen
ziehen sich aus der öffentlichkeit
zurück weil dort eben vieles verboten
ist durch die sittenpolizei und wenn sie
im iran unterwegs sind auf den partys
auf den einladungen erkennen sie dieses
land nicht wieder sie bekommen dort
alkohol drogen
es werden feste gefeiert es gibt
festliche musik alles natürlich unter
der hand sozusagen und es gibt dvd
raubkopien sie bekommen die neuesten
filme hollywoods in teheran ist diese
verzerrte wahrnehmung des irans ist
einfach thema in der sendung die sie
aktuell beim zdf redaktionell betreuen
und moderieren die sendung forum am
freitag so ein bisschen am rande bei uns
geht es auch viel um muslimische themen
und den islam in europa aber es zeigt
eben auch dass der islam nicht nur eine
seite
nämlich eben diese verschleierung oder
dass man sagte abfall vom glauben wird
mit dem tode bestraft das leider in iran
ja auch der fall ist wenn sie
konvertieren wollen oder den islam
ablehnen dann steht darauf zumindest die
nach an die todesstrafe es gibt sehr
viele facetten das heißt die menschen
haben trotzdem den verdammen nicht den
islam obwohl er ihn seit über 30 jahren
an die diktatur präsentiert sondern die
religion jeder liebt seine eigene
religion und sie hat ein
identitätsstiftendes merkmal was aber
viele auch in die identitätskrise bringt
weil es natürlich sehen dass was wir
unter islam verstehen wird uns hier
nicht vorgelebt es ist eine absolute
diktatur die dort herrscht ist es gibt
macht klicken auf die wir bestimmt noch
zu sprechen kommen und das land wird
absolut regiert von den pastoren von den
revolutionswächtern die natürlich im
namen des islam menschen verfolgen sie
verhaften und keinerlei freiheiten den
menschen leider zu bestehen
das größte missverständnis ist sehr
wahrscheinlich dass das man eben die
iraner für araber haben das am anfang
schon angesprochen
dagegen müssen sie sich wahrscheinlich
ständig werden dass das in persien ganz
anderen kulturellen historischen
hintergrund hat das ist vielen einfach
gar nicht bekannt das ganz wichtiger
punkt viele singer in der islamischen
republik ein widerspruch in sich islam
und republik auf das wird noch bestimmt
noch zu sprechen kommen ja sozusagen nur
den islam als vorherrschend aber die
iraner und das ist ganz wichtig für das
verständnis dieses landes haben eine
vorislamische geschichte
das heißt wir grenzen uns ganz stark
auch gegen die araber ab nicht nur
kulturell und zivilisatorisch sondern
wir haben über 3000 jahre kultur und
zivilisation und wir sind im siebten
jahrhundert von den arabern islamisiert
wollen sie haben es die religion des
islam gebracht wie wir auch von vielen
anderen von den mongolen von den türken
überrannt worden sind aber die perser
haben immer wieder ihre identität
behalten und auch ihre vor islamische
religion nämlich traktor wir haben in
diesen tagen feiern wir das iranische
neujahrsfest was die islamische republik
auch lange zeit versucht hat
abzuschaffen aber die iraner behalten
ihre identität auch ihre sprache die
eine indogermanische sprache ist und
keine semitische sprache wie bei den
arabern auch ein unterschied
also es gibt eine sehr starke identität
einen sehr starken patriotismus unter
den iranern den sie sich nicht nehmen
lassen und die sich auch in den ganzen
jahr tausende nicht haben
sie berufen sich auch heute noch gerne
zum beispiel auf den persischen groß
könig tyros der das erste weltreich der
geschichte gegründet hat der war es ja
auch die israeliten aus der
babylonischen gefangenschaft geführt hat
also solche dinge in der geschichte das
ist wichtig dass das erinnert sehr
wichtig für das verständnis auch wenn
wir dieser tag jetzt in einem interview
gehört haben wieder von präsident
ahmadinedschad den holocaust geleugnet
hat und dass er die zionisten quasi von
der bildfläche verschwunden haben will
muss man wissen
auch dies ist ein großes paradox in der
islamischen republik heute das nämlich
im iran darüber haben wir einen film
gemacht auch im zdf die größte jüdische
gemeinde außerhalb israels im nahen
osten lebt es gibt über 50.000 100.000
iranische juden es gibt über 15
jüdische gotteshäuser im iran
wir haben die gesehen wir haben sie
besucht und die können ihre religion
relativ frei sagt man ihn im rahmen
ihrer eigenen gotteshäuser leben es gab
große restaurants werden im krankenhaus
besucht bei juden auch muslime betreut
haben insofern ist das immer so eine
sache natürlich beruft man sich dort in
sagt wir sind zuerst iraner und dann
juden und ganz wichtig ist natürlich
auch zu wissen dass das judentum an sich
im iran wie sie es angedeutet haben eine
lange geschichte hat aber es gab nach
der revolution ein deal mit rumäne der
gesagt hat juden als religion
akzeptieren wir
sie haben auch einen
parlamentsabgeordneten dass die
wenigsten leute wissen aber das
zionistische regime israel also den
zionismus lehnen wir ab
und das ist eher die wie die juden heute
im iran auch leben können also sind sie
bekennen sich als juden zur religion des
judentums aber nicht zum zionismus
also das heißt auch ahmadinejad war sehr
ablehnt sind nicht juden an sich sondern
den staat israel richtig dass wir nach
oft veranstaltung das wird alles in
einen topf geworfen kann man sagen er
ist eigentlich kein antisemit sondern
ein anti zionist trotzdem kommt es
natürlich in der presse als antisemit
rüber wenn
will den staat israel nicht auslöschen
er sagt dass die geschichte den schon
israel von der landkarte verschwinden
lässt dass es auch eine wichtige
unterscheidung die falsch wiedergegeben
übersetzt wurde
natürlich gibt es da diese mit
antisemitismus gleichgesetzt aber einig
ist ein aktionismus der sich gegen den
staat israel und natürlich für die
palästinenser partei ergreifen so
ausdrückt aber juden an sich leben im
iran haben auch eine daseinsberechtigung
sind aber in letzter zeit immer wieder
verfolgt das muss man auch sagen aber
sie haben einen parlamentsabgeordneten
und haben eben auch dürfen ihre rechte
im parlament auch zur sprache bringen
sie haben das schon angesprochen dieser
widerspruch islam iran ist eine
islamische republik aber wie geht das
zusammen also wie kann ein gottesstaat
eine republik sein weil republik des
winter ganz demokratisch
das ist ein interessanter punkt ich
bezeichne den iran immer als demokratie
in der diktatur das heißt wir haben
benennen das islamische republik die
menschen sagen aber inzwischen auf den
straßen wenn sie mit entsprechend ist es
weder islamisch noch eine republik
weil nämlich die prinzipien des islam ja
so nicht wiedergegeben beiden im iran
eine republik ist es schon mal gar nicht
aber es gibt quasi demokratische
elemente wie ich es nenne es gibt ein
parlament und den präsidenten
die auch vom volk gewählt werden das hat
man vor wenigen wochen gesehen raabs
parlamentswahlen
aber sie werden in sofern er nicht
einfach jeder kann die richtig richtig
jeder demokratischen institution ist
eine quasireligiöse übergestülpt das
heißt wenn jemand für das parlament
kandidieren will muss er über den
wächterrat das ist eine quasi erfindung
der islamischen republik da sitzen
geistliche und gelehrte denn und die
müssen eben quasi ihr okay geben dass
jemand als parlamentsabgeordneter als
parlaments kandidat zugelassen wird und
da hebelt eben dann heben diese
institution diese diktatorischen
institutionen die demokratischen
institutionen wie präsident und
parlament aus denn viele reformer sind
bei der letzten wahl überhaupt nicht
zugelassen worden nach außen kann man
sagen es sind freie wahlen aber dann
kann der reformer zugelassen sind sind
es keine freien wahlen insofern sinn ist
scheint demokratische elemente inhalt
einzigartig glaube ich ist ja auch
dieses prinzip des obersten religiösen
führers also was ist das genau
eine erfindung von romani das ist
nämlich nicht etwas man man denkt
manchmal ja das ist eine religiöse
tradition eine islamische aber das ist
eine neue erfindung markante es man
kannte es schon der geschichte des
schiitischen islam der eine lange
geschichte hat und der im 15 jahrhundert
staatsreligion wurde in iran aber
rumänien hat es sehr gut verstanden mit
der islamischen revolution quasi ein
gottesstaat zu etablieren der
einzigartig ist eine theokratie politik
und religion gemischt sind und da kommt
genau die interessante punkt tritt
zutage die schäden wir waren eigentlich
eher eine dass man kristen schiitische
geistliche sie hatten sie waren nicht
weltlich zugewandt die war nicht
politisch tätig oder nicht unbedingt
sehr politisch aktiv und mit der
islamischen revolution traten diese
wende quasi zu tage dass rumänien gesagt
hat wir haben ein obersten religiösen
führer der über alles entscheidet da
alle gewalten auf sich auch vereinigt
auch ein faktum was zeigt dass es auf
keinen fall eine demokratie ist nämlich
die judikative exekutive und legislative
vereinigen sich in diesem obersten
religiösen führer gewalten
der präsident ist ein untergeordnetes
parlamenten untergeordnet das militär
ist ihm untergeordnet das heißt er ist
eine absolute diktatorische figur bella
hatte fahrig genannt oberster
rechtsgelehrter und dagegen haben sich
sogar führende geistliche wieder
inzwischen verstorbenen ayatollah
montazeri auch gewährt das rallye das
etabliert hat nur ganz kurz am als
zwischen erklärung was nochmal die
unterscheidung zwischen sunniten und
schiiten
das ist wichtig ja also im iran sind der
ich bin auch schiit genau man ist dann
wird quasi als muslimische schiitischen
muslimen im iran auch geboren
der islam setzt sich aus schiiten und
sunniten zusammen ist ungefähr 80 bis 90
prozent sunniten und 10 prozent 15
prozent schiiten die meisten davon oder
viele davon leben im iran der iran ist
fast 90 prozent schiiten
da geht es eigentlich darum quasi nach
dem tod des propheten mohammad gab es
ein streit darum wer dies die islamische
gemeinde führen soll
sunniten die mehrheit haben gesagt das
muss durch eine wahl passieren wir
müssen einen kalifen wählen der diese
islamische gemeinde dann ihr vorsteht
und sie führt und die schiiten am gesagt
nein das muss eine blues erfolge des
propheten muhammad sein für uns eine
schwierige genau das muss ein verwandter
eine erbfolge des propheten mohammad
zahlen und seines schwiegersohns ali
said ali die partei alice ist dann
daraus entstanden und dementsprechend
sind sind die iraner eben auch schiiten
die an zwölf imame glauben diese zwölfte
imam das ist sehr speziell der also wenn
ich richtig verstanden habe sollte er
noch leben der ist aber im verborgenen
soll wiederkommen richtig der ist das
ist der islamische messias der
verborgene zwölfte imam der ist nach
einer gewissen zeit in die verborgenheit
entrückt und man wartet täglich
stündlich auf seine wiederkehr
das ist ein volkslauf das eigene
schiitische glaube in iran daran glauben
wir an unseren islamischen messias der
eines tages nach einer zeit des chaos
und der ungerechtigkeit zurückkehren
wird und einen islamischen gerechten
gerechten islamischen staat etablieren
wird und das ist höchst politisch der
jetzige oberste religiöse für also kamen
quasi der stellvertreter ist das ist der
statthalter des verborgenen imam auf
erden und wenn ihr verborgen immer eines
tages eben zurückkommt dann wird er
diesen obersten religiösen führern
derzeit ajatollah khamenei ersetzen und
das ist ganz ganz brisant derzeit im
internen machtkampf in iran sie haben
auf der einen seite den obersten
religiösen führer der eigentlich die
kontrolle über alles hat auch das
atomprogramm
aber sie haben auch einen präsidenten
der für sich in anspruch nimmt das
atomprogramm zu vertreten die
außenpolitik zu vertreten und auch
mancher beruft sich explizit auf diesen
verborgenen imam was in der realität
manchmal sehr grotesk ist wenn er
eingeladen ist stellt er neben sein glas
wasser ein zweites glas wasser und die
menschen fangen wieso machst du da sagte
es könnte sein dass der verborgenen imam
zurückkommt und da ich seine ankunft
stündlich erwarte inhaltlich ein platz
für ihn frei und ein glas wasser und das
ist natürlich radikal gegen den obersten
religiösen führer gerichte pläne
bekämpfen will
richtige oberste führer der ist zwar
selbst kein geistlicher aber ergibt sich
diesen geistlichen anspruch auch ein
trick von ahmadinedschad um quasi gegen
den klerus der im parlament die mehrheit
hat rahmen getreuen durchsetzt ist die
ihn anklagen die in korruption vorwerfen
ihn des amtes entheben wollen um diesen
klerus beiseite zu schaffen
das hat zum teil auch machtpolitische
gründe sie wissen der präsident
ahmadinedschad war ja selbst ein
revolutionswächter und hat im iran irak
krieg gekämpft und das ist auch so ein
interner machtkampf wo gesagt wird wir
haben gekämpft wie revolutionswächter
haben unser land gegen den irak
verteidigt wo wart ihr geistlichen
eigentlich bei diesem acht jahre
dauernden krieg ihr habt eure freunde
gesichert und jetzt wollt ihr quasi der
der islamischen republik vorherrschen
sie gehört uns aber ist denn
ahmadinedschad wirklich eine religiöse
fanatiker oder instrumentalisierte
einfach auch für populistische zwecke
die religion
ich habe jetzt auch mehrmals erlebt auf
verschiedenen konferenzen und habe in
den interviews gesehen ich glaube hat
schon einen durch und durch islamische
welt bild das muss man ein
apokalyptisches war da eben an die
apokalypse an diesen verborgenen imam an
die rückkehr glaubt und dementsprechend
eben die apokalypse herbei sind damit
eben dieser verborgenen imam zurückkommt
er meint es wirklich ernst und das sieht
man auch daran dass er beispielsweise im
iran einen wallfahrtsort den es auch
bisher gab für den verborgenen imam
jamal khan
der liegt unweit von teheran dass er den
für millionen von dollar
auch hat herrichten lassen als
pilgerstätte wobei man wissen muss das
eigentlich unsere religiösen hochburg
ghom ist wo der rumänien auch früher her
kam und auch lange zeit im gelehrt hat
also noch mal auf die frage zurück zum
ahmadinedschad benutzt einerseits
instrumentalisiert natürlich die
religion weil er selbst kein geistlicher
ist noch keine geistliche kluft trägt
kann
muller oder kanada ist ein hoher
schiitischer geistlicher
andererseits ist er schon sehr gläubig
und bietet auch täglich und das sehen
wir auch den konferenzen wo sich die
auszeit nimmt und zum beten geht aber
jetzt nach den parlamentswahlen anfang
märz für ahmadinedschad nicht gut also
dass ist der machtkampf hat sich eher
zugunsten rahmen des verlages
richtig das ist ein problem das wir auch
derzeit im iran sehen er hat die
parlamentswahlen verloren und die frage
ist jetzt wie wir dieser machtkampf
ausgehen wird er diese religiöse
apokalypse an die er glaubt die rückkehr
des verborgenen imam wieder das
beschleunigen es gibt im internet viele
beispiele dafür dass er quasi predigt
der verborgenen haben würde zurückkommen
im ausland hat man die furcht dass
ahmadinedschad zur atombombe greift um
dieses zu erzwingen um das zu erzwingen
um dieses chaos herbeizuführen ich halte
das für übertrieben
ich halte ihn rein rationalen akteur er
weiß genau glaube ich was er tut
aber er steht mit dem rücken zur wand
und spiele die nationale karte neben
dieser apokalyptischen karte er sagt wir
wollen einen iranischen islam und kein
islamischen iran setzt auf diesem
patriotismus der für die iraner sehr
wichtig ist die frustriert sind über
diese islamische republik und dieser
machtkampf ist sehr spannend und wir
wissen nicht wie er ausgeht aber viele
in iran sagen ahmadinejad hat überhaupt
keine bedeutung mehr im ausland wird er
viel höher bewertet als im inland da
gibt es inzwischen ganz andere player
wie beispielsweise parlamentspräsident
larijani der ein betreuer von kriminell
ist also wenn die kommenden wochen noch
einiges mit sich bringen
was bedeutet denn die jetzige situation
für die menschen im land sie haben ein
bisschen angesprochen dass die menschen
leben in zwei welten im privaten im
öffentlichen so aufgespalten also was
wir feststellen ist der iran wie schon
erwähnt ist ein sehr komplexes land wir
müssen wissen
der iran ist auch ein sehr junges land
die 77 millionen einwohner über 60
prozent sind unter 30 jahre alt und
kennen diese islamisch nur noch diese
islamische republik kennen die startzeit
eigentlich nur aus den büchern und sagen
immer wieder dass wände immer wieder bei
interviews bei unseren recherchereisen
dass sie sagen früher war es ganz toll
und was sie uns erzählt und heute leben
wir in einer furchtbaren diktatur
haben sich zurückgezogen in ihr
privatleben das internet ist sehr
wichtig sie müssen wissen dass unsere
sprache fach sie die viertwichtigste
sprache im internet ist die menschen
haben eben als dieses internet benutzen
sie als tor zur welt weil sonst alles
verboten und auch alles es gibt zensur
auch das internet wird blockt jedes gibt
eine cyber polizei die darauf schaut
dass dieses sozusagen das internet nach
islamischen richtlinien vor sich geht
was ich absurd finde und viele flüchten
sich eben in diese in diese cyberwelt
dass das internet und versuchen da ein
stück weit ihrer freiheiten auch zu
genießen aber und das muss man auch
tragischerweise dazu sagen eine solche
religiöse diktatur über 30 jahre bringt
auch viele psychische krankheiten mit
sich
dieses zurückziehen in das private ist
auch für viele frustrierend in dem sinne
als dass sie beispielsweise und eine
hohe arbeitslosigkeit die
wirtschaftssituation johannes verheerend
und viele junge menschen im fallenden
drogenabhängig gibt die höchste zahl der
drogensüchtigen weltweit man schätzt
eine dunkelziffer von 10.000.000 drogen
ein schuss heroin ist günstiger als ein
liter milch
es ist also eine fatale situation die
auch ausgenutzt wird durch den
drogenhandel durch afghanistan von den
revolutionswächtern die diese drogen
auch vermutet man an die jugendlichen
weitergeben um sie eben ruhig zu halten
um sie nicht auf die straße zu bringen
und zum protestieren ist die situation
für die frauen auch eine sehr
interessante entwicklung einerseits
wissen wir natürlich es gibt eine
steuerpflicht und im westen glaubt man
die frauen sind unter druck den iran was
wir aber vor ort beobachten ist dass
noch nie so viele frauen einen
universitäten studiert haben wie heute
es gibt eine männerquote über 60 prozent
frauen einen universitäten an
unglaublich freut mich sehr für dieses
land hat einen ganz simplen grund durch
die steuerpflicht sind viele religiöse
familien sehen jetzt die möglichkeit
ihre frauen die sie möglicherweise zu
zeiten des schalls der schleier verboten
war nicht aus dem haus gelassen gerade
auf ländlichen gebiet jetzt die frauen
auch in die universitäten in die schulen
aber auch an ihre an ihre arbeitsplätze
gehen können also ein sehr paradoxes
facettenreiches land wo es verschiedene
entwicklungen gibt sie haben über 100
tageszeitungen
das internet habe ich schon erwähnt sie
haben zeitschriften es gibt viele frauen
die beispielsweise denken sie nur an die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin schirin ebadi
es gibt eine total lebendige
zivilgesellschaft also der iran lebt er
ist nicht tot
obwohl die grüne bewegung ziemlich am
boden ist und wir haben noch einiges zu
erwarten was uns natürlich für die
kommenden wochen monate und jahre
hoffnung macht dann werden wir gerade
wieder bei der beim grünen sommer von
iran und der schluss frage was glauben
sie denn also ist die rede die revolte
dida begonnen hat 2009 jetzt erstmal vom
tisch oder schlummert das irgendwo im
untergrund so dass es jederzeit wieder
aufbrechen kann und sich dann auch
durchsetzen kann
wie schätzen sie seien also was die
grüne bewegung an sich angeht ist die
lage ziemlich am boden die wir wissen ja
die führer der grünen bewegung mussawi
und karubi sind unter hausarrest
die gefängnisse im iran sind voll das
ist das größte gefängnis beispielsweise
für journalisten
aber der iran hat auch eine der höchsten
hinrichtungs raten weltweit amnesty
international hat das gerade vor kurzem
rausgebracht das fast 700 menschen im
letzten jahr allein im iran hingerichtet
worden sind sie kennen das problem der
steinigung dass wir mit frau sakineh
ashtiani hatten im norden irans es ist
ein bisschen schwierig da eine
prophezeiung zu machen ich glaube unter
der glut lodert es stark aber inwieweit
die grüne bewegung das sein wird das
keine volksbewegung weiß war er die
mittelschicht also den der grünen
bewegung ist es nicht gelungen die ganze
volksbewegung zu mobilisieren
aber die opposition ist sehr wach schon
sich das ausland an es gibt viele viele
iraner dem ausland tätig sind und auch
der sohn des verstorbenen star aus
amerika seine mutter ist ja auch noch
lebt ja auch noch als insofern es gibt
eine sehr lebendige zivilgesellschaft
auch im iran die dagegen arbeitet aber
sie müssen natürlich wissen dass der
iran an der furchtbarsten macht
sicherheitsapparate hat auch in syrien
tätig aber vor allem im iran die
hisbollah unterstützt und ähnliches also
das iranische volk wird wird unterdrückt
wir haben eine ganz schwierige situation
und wir hoffen natürlich dass da noch
potenzial übrig bleibt um eines tages
nochmal diesen iranischen fröhlich zu
erhalten
das hoffen wir auch ich bedanke mich
sehr herzlich für das gespräch bei ihm
kam ralf jahren kritisch
dieses gespräch können sie jederzeit
noch einmal sehen auf unserer website
und natürlich gibt es davon auch eine
dvd bei schweizer radio und fernsehen
redaktion sternstunden 80 52 zürich ihre
e mail erreicht uns um das stern
copyright sf punkt ch und wir bleiben
beim iran jenem land das uns heute den
ganzen morgen beschäftigen wird wir
zeigen jetzt gleich den preisgekrönten
zeichentrickfilms persepolis ein
poetisch berührende einblicke in 20
jahre islamische republik mit den augen
von hasan und der iran hat viele
gesichter im westen kennen wir vor allem
die bilder machtvoller mullahs doch die
persische kultur
sie gehörten ältesten der menschheit ein
gespräch
geschichte vermittelt sich am besten
über geschichten am tauglichen sind
lebensgeschichten unser lässt uns die
comic zeichnerin marjane satrapi
denn auch an ihrem leben teilhaben an
ihrem leben mit einem schwierigen land
deinem leben in iran
zehn jahre ist sie alt als der schah
1979 ins exil geht und die islamische
republik ausgerufen wird ihrem zunächst
kindlichen später jugendlichen blick auf
die veränderungen in iran hat sagt gabi
festgehalten zunächst dann comic dann
mit einem gezeichneten film film und
comic sind grafisch überraschend von
höchster güte und bestechen durch ihre
historische genauigkeit persepolis von
marjane satrapi ein vielfach
ausgezeichnetes meisterwerk nicht
zuletzt weil es eine hervorragende
geschichtslektion in sachen iran ist